hi everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast Katy one cancer immunotherapy
presented by dr. Gordon J Freeman I'm
Christina jewel of labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider a virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning here's how
the presentation works we want to hear
from you questions comments and you and
answers can be submitted via the green
Q&A button at the lower left of your
screen we'll try it is everyone but if
not we will make sure to follow up with
you by email you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower left right hand corner of the
slide window if you can't hear or see
this presentation properly let us know
by clicking on the support button at the
top right of the Q&A are you on the top
right or in the Q&A button on the lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Gordon J flamin
Gordon Freeman PhD works in the
department of medical oncology at Dana
Farber Cancer Institute and his
professor of medicine at Harvard Medical
School dr. Freeman earned his BA in
biochemistry and molecular biology and
PhD in microbiology and molecular
genetics from Harvard University his
research has identified the major
pathways that control the immune
response by inhibiting T cell activation
pd-1 PDO 1mb 7 2 - CT la does for or
stimulating t-cell activation
b7 - um cd28 in 2000 dr. Freeman
discovered PDL 1 and PDL 2 and showed
they were lichens for PD 1
defining the pd-1 pathway and the drug
target block the interaction he showed
the function of pd-1 was the inhibit
immune responses and that walk aid
enhanced immune responses he showed that
PDL one is highly expressed on many
solid tumors such as breast and lung as
well as some he needs logic of
malignancies and allows his term tumors
to inhibit immune attack he received the
2014 William B Cooley award for
distinguished research in tumor indian
tumor immunology for his work that led
to development of pd-1 pathway blockade
for cancer immunotherapy i will now turn
this presentation over to dr. Freeman
dr. Freeman
good morning I'm Gordon Freeman from the
Dana Farber Cancer Institute and I
wanted to talk today about pd-1
immunotherapy could you put up the the
talk slides I only see the disclosure
slides right now good
good so these are my disclosures so
immunology has offered hope for curing
cancer for the last hundred years but
you couldn't go into your doctor's
office and get an effective
immunotherapy now that's changed in the
last couple of years and what's
different now and what's changed is we
have a new strategy and that new
strategy is to block the pathways used
by tumors to inhibit the anti-tumor
immune response and this has been termed
checkpoint blockade by Jim Allison
now t-cells are the white blood cells
that can kill cancer cells and when a
disease starts you only have a tiny
number of t-cells that can attack that
disease so for instance right now you
probably only have a thousand t-cells
that could attack Zika virus and that
isn't an effective fighting force
but once the immune system recognizes
and it a disease the T cells become
activated and start to frantically
proliferate and over a week they go from
say a thousand t-cells to millions of
t-cells and millions of t-cells can
orchestrate and mount an effective
immune response now cell activation
requires two signals the first signal is
provided by the T cell receptor
interacting with peptide antigen on the
antigen presenting cell and that gives
the response specificity but T cells
need a second signal a co stimulatory
signal for full activation and that's
what I study and the surprise over the
last twenty years is that they're both
positive and negative second signals now
I got into this field for studying the
b7 1 and b7 2 molecules which are the
receptors for ctla-4 and cd28
now when the human genome began to be
sequence we looked for what molecules
were cousins to
be seven molecules and we identified two
that we call PBL one and PBL two and
with Clive would we show these are the
binding partners the ligands for a
molecule called pv one and when PDL 1 or
PDL 2 bound to PD one the resulted in
tyrosine phosphorylation of the
cytoplasmic domain of pd-1 and this
recruited phosphatases such as SHP 2 and
this led to a reduced activity of the
proximal signaling kinases of the t-cell
receptor and cd28 pathway and this
results in reduced TCR signaling less
cytokine production reduced target cell
lysis it also has effects on altering
lymphocyte motility and metabolically
reprogramming the t-cell now this work
was published in 2000 and it identified
the drug target identified drugs that
would block the interaction of pd-1 with
PDL one lpt1
was cloned in the 1990s of by the Honjo
lab from a cd3 activated t cell
hybridomas undergoing activation induce
cell death and so they called it
programmed F 1 but this is somewhat of a
misnomer because it doesn't directly
activate caspases and cause cell death
or apoptosis like the CD 95 or fast
molecules you can have an indirect
effect on cell death by reduce cytokines
less survival factors like bcl-xl or
more Bhim as shown by Dom now we have
negative signals like PD 1 for an
important reason
and Arlene sharp and Jessica Hondo's lab
has studied the knockout mice and they
show that the PD one pathway is
important in maintaining tolerance
in two and sounding in response after
the elimination of disease and it
prevents too strong an immune response
from damaging tissues now soon after we
cloned PDL 1 we identified PDL 2 as a
second ligand now we knew we had an
pathway that inhibited immune responses
but we discovered something surprising
we found that PDL 1 was expressed on
solid tumor cell lines not unlike a
typical immune molecule and this slide
shows PDL one expression on breast
cancer cell lines and we said that this
might represent a shield against the
immune system by cancer and this is
proven to be a remarkably accurate
prediction when people began to look at
PDL one expression on actual tumors
first shown by lightning Chen um we
found that PDL one was expressed on
about 30% of solid tumors and selected
monologic malignancies and this
inhibited the anti-tumor immune response
so here in brown is the PDL one
expression and you can see expression on
the surface of kidney tumors or on the
right expression on a lung cancer so PDL
one turns off human response but in a
cancer patient the whole immune response
is it turned off a cancer patient kiss
can still mount a fine immune response
against the common cold for instance
there's no PDL one expression in the
nasal cavity and so there's a good
immune response
however locally in the cancer in the
lung you can see there's a lot of PDL
one expression and this turns off the
local immune response so
Immy ologist have tried to stimulate an
advert to anti-tumor immune response for
many years but it hasn't worked and one
of the reasons that directly stimulating
the immune response hasn't worked in
real patients is that the immune
response has gotten ahead and if the
t-cell recognizes a tumour that comes a
little activated but it makes them gamma
interferon and that is seen by in
interferon receptors and up regulates
PDL one expression
so once the tumor gets ahead the very
act of recognizing the tumor turns off
the University response so PDL one
expression can come in several different
patterns and this is a pattern which has
been termed adaptive of immune response
by Janet Tong and here what you see in a
melanoma in brown on the right is PDL
one expression on the periphery of the
melanoma but not middle and if you look
on the left you see in brown PD one
expression on T cells and these t-cells
are held up at the border of the tumor
and don't really enter it very much so
this locally turns off the T cells now
we identified the drug target so we made
antibodies against PDL 1 and PDL one as
did multiple other groups and we showed
that if you block the interaction of PDL
one with PD one that you activated the
immune response you got an enhanced
immune response with increased t-cell
production of cytokines like gamma
interferon and increase killing of tumor
cell targets so where is a new
checkpoint blockade function a Jim
Allison pioneered ctla4 blockade and
this is blockade of an amino inhibitory
pathway the interaction of b7 with ctle
or
which primarily occurs in the lymph node
where there's significant b7 expression
on astron presenting cells in contrast
we had a different idea we wanted to
block the immuno inhibition by the tumor
in the tumor micro-environment
so we wanted to block PDL one expression
on the tumor on infiltrating myeloid
derives suppressor selves stromal cells
answering presenting cells and so pd-1
blockade works within the tumor in the
tumor microenvironment now multiple
pharmaceutical companies have developed
agents that block the PD one PDL one
interaction and these include Nivola map
by Crystal Meyer sliver and Pemble is
amount by Merck or at ease aluminum by
Roche in addition multiple other
companies have made drugs that block of
the pathway and these have been enrolled
in clinical trials now I'm a PhD
immunologist not a physician and this
slide was of a kidney cancer trial was
kindly provided by Chuck Drake and the
what this shows is the analysis of 34
cancer patients with the pd-1 antibody
Nivola map now what we're looking at
here is each line follows one on the
growth or de munition of one tumor and
it follows the change in tumor size now
some tumors continue to grow in the
presence of PDL one and go on to a
different therapy in contrast some of
the lines go down the tumor is reducing
in size and it's a good response if
there is too much drinks in size by 30%
or more this is called an objective
response and in this clinical trial 29
percent of the patients
had an objective clinical response what
was impressive is that in this trial all
the patients stopped therapy after about
two years and after stopping therapy the
tumour didn't immediately regrow you can
see in the red circle that the tumor
stays small and there's survival even
off a drug now this slide shows the
response rates to PD one pd-1 inhibitors
of four in multiple clinical trials in
fact over 250 clinical trials up to 2015
now the first study was published by
julie brahmer and suzanne to Polian and
what this was in multiple tumor types
and showed positive responses um you see
about a thirty five percent response
rate in melanoma 30 percent in bladder
twenty percent in a number of tumor
types pv one therapy doesn't work in all
tumor types for instance there's a
pretty low response in : there's very
good response in Hodgkin so in greed now
are the tumors where the trial results
have been successful enough to lead to
fda approval of the pd one drug for that
tumor type so there's approvals now in
advanced melanoma bladder lung head and
neck kidney and Hodgkin's lymphoma um
just to make sure that i'm on with the
moderator just please give me a type
message that everything is good
all right good good to hear it okay so
I'd like to emphasize that pd-1 therapy
is different from chemotherapy it's not
a cell poison you're not trying to
directly kill the tumor cell instead
you're trying to let the two immune
system become activated and the immune
system killed it too honey
so the pd1 therapy is well tolerated of
there's no blood cell health decline no
hair loss there is some nausea it's got
an accepted safety profile the most
serious adverse events are auto immune
mediated like pneumonitis or colitis
immune attack against some organ in the
body
this occurs in about 10% of patients and
so this is different from the
complications of chemotherapy so
physicians are really going to have to
learn to manage a different spectrum of
adverse events than those seen in
chemotherapy now the pd-1 antibody is
delivered with about a half hour
intravenous drug infusion of in an
outpatient basis so this is potentially
if physicians become comfortable with it
at Community Hospital medicine now the
other thing that's notable about the
pd-1 therapy can be if it works the
quality of life can be good this is some
studies from barmal and picard presented
at SI pc and what you see is this looks
at the quality of life of a lung cancer
patient who's doing well on chemotherapy
box attacks and the quality of life of
the people patient is basically the
quality of life of the lung cancer
patient in contrast if you respond to PD
1 and a 2 and L your quality of life
returns pretty much to the population
norm and one of the authors was Holder
the same this suggests that
prolonged survival occurs with a
resumption of normal life which is a
real improvement
now another notable thing is the
checkpoint blockade has been studied
both in elderly and younger patients the
cutoff being about 65 to 70 years and
about 3,000 patients were analyzed and
the hazard ratio the odds of success in
complications are about the same in the
younger patients or the older patients
so it can work equally well in the aging
and this can lead to successes such as a
90 year old with metastatic melanoma and
four brain metastases who was treated
with the PD one active body hammer
Elizabeth now predictive biomarkers are
really essential to getting the right
treatment to the right patient and the
first round breaking study by Coppola in
of was black and white on the left here
you showed that the tumor was PDL one
positive
there was about a thirty six percent
response rate in contrast if the tumor
was PDL one negative there were no
responders multiple other studies have
shown that it's not quite so black and
white though the general trend is
satellite so if the tumor in the tumor
micro-environment
expresses PDL one there's a higher
response rate but there's some modest
level of response in patients whose
tumors are PDL one so PDL one expression
isn't a good enough to biomarker to say
yes no we need something better though
we can guide therapy so it used to be
the PDL 1 and you know history chemistry
was difficult and artsy however a lot of
effort has been put into developing good
at buttons and they're really now 5 good
widely available and University
chemistry antibodies for PDL 1 the
original Brown groundbreaking words is
done with 5 h1 from
chen but they're now antibodies
available from Merck BMS Loesch and in
addition antibodies from my lab and cell
signaling technology all of which worked
well some of these see the outside of
the PDL one molecule where some see the
inside so for instance the nine a 11 and
the 142 antibodies see the inside
cytoplasmic domain of PDL one and to
give good immunohistochemistry as shown
in these slides where you can see nice
PDL one expression on the cell surface
now with sabina Signoret ii we looked at
PDL 1 immunity mister chemistry and try
to see whether there was concordance or
discordance ii between primary tumor and
metastasis in renal cell carcinoma and
we looked at 53 cases and what we see is
that 33 of those cases are negative in
both the primary and metastasis and so
are important now the 20 positive cases
what we saw is that 9 had a PDL one
expression both in primary and
metastasis and so were concordant about
the three had expression only metastasis
and eight had expression only in the
primary so what Sabina emphasizes is
that PDL one positivity was
heterogeneous and almost exclusively
detected in the high nuclear grade area
of the tumor an assessment is a
predictive biomarkers may require
analysis of metastatic lesions a
pathologist should really select the
high-grade tumor areas on to avoid false
negatives now in addition PDL one
expression can be better
heterogeneous within the same tumor here
you see little PDL one expression in a
low-grade area of a kidney cancer but a
lot of expression in a hydrating
now when the immune system attacks a
tumor
what does it see in the tumor to attack
and what the tumor sees is changes in
the tumor cell and these are primarily
protein coding changes brought about by
mutations which change the amino acid in
protein and these are called tumor neo
antigens and there are really two
evolutionary processes going on in
cancer there's rare mutations such as in
say B Rath or Rath which are driver
mutations which drive the proliferation
of the tumor but there are many
different passenger mutations which can
change protein coding sequence and lead
to tumor Neil Afton's as indicated by
these symbols in the tumor but there's
also another evolutionary process going
on the tumor and this has really been
pioneered by Bob Shriver and what he's
shown us is that the immune system
eliminates many early tumors but the
tumors that grow and become a medical
problem have learned how to evade the
immune system by expression of molecules
like PDL one or ideal tgf-beta aisle 10
loss of MHC class 1 or two on so that
there's really two evolutionary
processes going on and one thing that's
really notable is that if you target
just a driver mutation um if you target
just one thing in a tumor the tremendous
mutational heterogeneity of the tumor
will learn how to evade it and become
resistant what's good about
immunotherapy is it engages the immune
system which has billions of t-cell
receptors billions of antibody molecules
and thousands of pattern recognition
molecules which can recognize the
changes in the Trinity so the immune
system is also an evolving system which
can keep up with the evolution
a tumor now on the right here is the of
a patient's response in the melanoma to
the b-raf targeted kinase inhibitor
velma raffinate the wonderful thing
about the tki is if you have the
mutation you're almost a hundred percent
likely to respond to it but this
response is evaded because it's just one
target and after a year so the patient
the tumor becomes resistant to that one
targeted therapy some of the newer TKIs
can be better and give three or more
years of benefit um in contrast on the
left is why there's so much enthusiasm
for immunotherapy um the green line
analyzes about 2,000 patients who have
been treated with the ctla4 antibody it
aluminum and what you see is that
patients are only treated for about one
year with the CTA or antibody and then
stop treating about 20% of the patients
by year three are alive and if you
follow these patients out for years four
five six seven eight nine out of ten
years they're still doing well they're
still alive and this is what s let's
talk about a pure now pv1 hasn't been
analyzed for as long
um in the blue line is a trial reported
by Steve Cody and Jen wallchuck and it
shows that PD one also has a survival
benefit of about thirty five percent and
that this is enduring and it follows
patients out up to about five years now
ctla-4 has only been clinically approved
as a single agent in melanoma in
contrast pd-1 has now been approved in
six tumor types
with successful clinical trials in
multiple other cancer types
so pd-1 is a broader immunotherapy now
understanding the immunology and
genetics has helped scientists identify
groups that will respond well to the PD
one pineal one learning murder ship at
the dana-farber Cancer Institute has
analyzed Hodgkin's lymphoma and what
she's shown is that almost all Hodgkin's
lymphoma genetically amplified the PDL 1
and PDL to chromosomal locus so the all
Hodgkin's lymphoma Express a lot of PDL
1 and PDL 2 and they really depend on it
and if you block PD one you get 87
percent response rate in Hutchinson Tomo
the group at Hodgins at Johns Hopkins
reason that since Neil actions are so
important that if you had a tumor type
which had a defect in DNA repair which
would lead to lots of DNA damage and
lots of mutations um such as the
microsatellite stable of in stable type
of colorectal cancer that you have a
highly mutated tumor with a lot of
targets and indeed their prediction is
spot-on and you get a 62 percent
response rate um in tumors with defects
and DNA repair now it's been estimated
that about 25 percent of human cancers
may be caused by viruses such as
papilloma virus or Merkel cell
polyomavirus and these Express foreign
viral antigens and the immune system is
really good at seeing barring and so
there's good response rates in Merkel
cell or head and neck tumor and really
we want to creatively think what other
tumors cell types may have a defect that
makes them highly responsive to immunity
now the real challenge now is to only 60
of 60 to 80% of patients don't get
benefit from pd-1 inhibitors and the
goal now is to bring clinical benefit by
immunotherapy to these other patients
and this is going to come about through
combination pedigrees now why did the
t-cells meet pd12 block blockade to
attack the tumor and the reason is that
the anti-tumor immune response is a
years long struggle the immune system is
tried to attack the tumor all these
years but the tumor is evaded the immune
attack and the t-cells have tried to
attack fail and become exhausted and
this idea comes about through a
collaboration with La Fiamma in January
and t-cell exhaustion however is more
than just expression of pd-1
exhausted tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
can express multiple and you know
inhibitory receptors including all the
ones shown on this slide including
ctla-4 lag 3 10 3 digit and these are
all druggable targets that scientists
and pharma companies are developing
drugs for tumor immunotherapy now so the
future is clearly combination therapy
building on a foundation of pd-1
but adding other checkpoints such as
ctla4 lag 3 or 10 3 or activating
molecules like CD 137 ox40 or IKOS or
stimulatory cytokines such as il-2 or
il-12 now Allen Clements room first
shown the effects of pd-1
with CTL 8 or and I'm showing going to
show you some combination studies in
mouse model of glioblastoma because this
is a tough model in the brain with
immune privilege where the immune system
doesn't get to easily so this work was
done with David Reardon and prefer Coca
Cola sour Klein and the tumor is
implanted into the brain of a mouse and
it develops and after about two weeks we
begin therapy with ctla-4 and or pv-1
antibodies and what we see is that in
this late model that ctla-4 alone gives
some benefit but not long-term survivors
PD one F button gives about 50%
survivors but the combination of pd-1
and ctla-4 gave seven out of eight
survivors in this experiment now this is
basically visualizing the tumor in the
brain of a mouse with luminescence and
what you see is the tumor in control
group begins to develop and then grows
very large in contrast in the treatment
group with PD one ctla4 the tumor begins
it grows larger but then the
immunotherapy kicks in and eliminates
the to the checkpoint blockade causes
much more immune infiltration of t-cells
into the tumor as indicated by these
brown t-cells in the two brain tumor and
in addition the checkpoint blockade has
an effect on t-cells the PD one results
in a lot more t NK cells in the tumor of
the ctla4 not so much so we also saw
that in the brain the NK cells expressed
more CD 86 molecules as a reflection of
activation so we wondered whether NK
cells were critical in the brain and we
used antibodies to eliminate cd8 cells
or NK cells in the brain
now the blue here shows the effect of
pd-1 antibody alone and if you add NK
1.1 of in the green with PB 1 to
eliminate the NK cells you show the
treatment is just as effective so NK
cells aren't absolutely essential in the
brain though they may contribute in
contrast in this purplish you see that
if you eliminate cd8 t-cells that the
treatment doesn't work so cd8 t-cells
are essential and in other experiments
Sara also showed that cd4 cells are
essential for the success of immunity so
it requires all the arms of an immune
response so though we think NK cells are
important one of the obvious evasion
mechanisms to immunotherapy might be
loss of MHC by the tumor but the immune
system has lots of ways to attack and if
a tumor loses MHC becomes much more
susceptible to NK cell lysis and here
with roberto Bellucci and jerry ribs
we've shown that NK cells do express
pd-1 and if you block PB one on NK cells
you get better lysis by the NK cells so
the PD one blockade can enhance immune
response by multiple arms of the immune
system so we wondered whether we could
use the wonderful TCGA database RNA
expression of of tumors to help us guide
immunotherapy development and there are
a number of other genes in the b7 gene
family in addition to PDL 1 and PDL to
these include b7 h3 and h4 about 20
members of the buter villain gene family
VISTA Aiko's living H HLA two anomalies
and so we asked are these expressed by
tumors and I got a Sam Freeman to
analyze x
of these molecules in normal kidney
shown in blue versus kidney cancer of in
this reddish color and what he found was
that kidney cancer was rather
extraordinary over on the right what you
can see is there's much more cd8
expression and cd4 x-team expression
reflective of a lot of infiltrating
immune cd8 killer cells and myeloid
cells and when you look at the b7 family
what you see is that there's more PDL to
more b7 h3 surprisingly less b7h or more
Vista more h HL o 2 and so these are all
now targets for immunotherapy of kidney
cancer and we went on to do some
immunity chemistry for the Vista
molecule and we see that on the left
this that can be expressed by the kidney
cancer cells on the right it can be
expressed on just on the infiltrating
immune cells and not on the kidney so
you really need to look at the actual
kidney to distinguish where the
molecules expressed now there are many
more combinations possible including
alkalotic viruses chemotherapy radiation
therapy and targeted therapies
epigenetic modifiers such as hvac
inhibitors are very promising blockade
of hospital siri in addition once you
block immune suppression by the tumor
this really enables other therapies such
as that scenes or stimulations by scheme
or TLR agonist gm-csf or interference or
cd4 t animism
the real key is to block the tumor from
turning off the immune system other
combinations include depleting other
immunosuppressive cells in tumor
micro-environment like MD SC s and T
regs or blocking other immunosuppressive
molecules like I do or tgf-beta
in addition there's a lot of creativity
going into adding back immune cells such
as car T cells or TCR engineered T cells
or NK cells and these T cells such as
Karthik ought T cells and then can over
time become exhausted and with way
marasco's group we've shown that if you
include PDL one a dividing with a car T
cell that this lets the car T cell work
longer and better in addition a number
of classical therapies such as surgery
or radiation can work together with PT
one blockade um in it particular many
types of chemotherapy might be thought
as just dividing killing all dividing
cells but some have actually been shown
to work with immunotherapy and this
shows basically a paper we've done with
Kristina
burski and Mikkel picnic at and this
looks at a genetic model of lung cancer
and here in the dark blue is growing
tumor in the lung so on the upper left
is large tumor growing in the untreated
mouse now this tumor didn't respond to
PD one and C tailing old therapy and it
responded weakly to of the combination
of oxalá pocky and cyclic phosphate
however what was surprising they
discovered was that when you killed the
tumors by the occipital cyclothymia
combination that that caused the tumor
to die in a way which was singlet or e2
the immune system as you're presenting
cells took up the tumor became activated
and presented it to the unisys and when
you blocked PT one in ckle for that
combination then really succeeded and
did well so there's chemotherapy
combinations that can combine with
immunotherapy so
what happens when tumors respond to PD
one immune therapy but then develop
resistance and this work comes from the
Tim three molecule that we discovered
with Jason Galia Vijay true true and
goes into the crime and we showed that
Tim three has two primary livings um
phosphatidylserine in a deep pot binds
to a deep binding pocket and Vijay
Cooter's group has shown the collectin
of sugar binding molecule binds to
sugars on the glock oscillations of the
Tim three molecule and we think these
work together of to transduce Tim three
signals and inhibit immune responses and
with show Nick Keanu and Assaraf a Kwok
Wong and Peter Hanuman we showed that in
patients where therapy PB 1 blockade
losses advocacy that it's associated
with upregulation of additional immune
checkpoints and this work was again done
in at a genetic model of lung cancer and
show Han Ezra treated this uh genetic
lung cancer model with PD one antibody
and the tumor was responsive for a
number of weeks but then began to become
resistant and grow again and they looked
at RNA expression in the untreated
versus the resistant tumor and what they
found is the resistant tumor developed a
lot of expression of the tin free
molecule or lanky and so these are
additional partners so they went on and
showed that in the lung cancer of in the
mouse that in the untreated Mouse in the
clear circles
there was little kin free expression in
the sensitive tumor there was just a
little tip three expression but as the
tumor became resistant eighty-one it
developed a lot of Tim 3 expression now
Peter identified some
one cancer patients but initially
responded to pb-1 therapy but then
become unresponsive and developed
resistance now the primary tumor in blue
didn't express much pbteen 10 3 and in
clear the control lung infusion didn't
effect a moderate amounts of Tim 3 but
when the tumor became resistant in red
it expressed a lot of 10 3 so Ezra and
Shohei went back to the mouse model and
what they showed is it if a mouse lung
tumor became resistant pd-1 therapy but
that you then added 10 3 therapy in the
red did you get additional clinical
benefit and the mouse would do well for
a while before declining so the
combination of PD 1 and 2 3 can benefit
when you develop PD one resistance so in
beginning to wrap up I'd say it's really
an exciting and great time to be an
oncologist because it's a better time
for patients PT 1 and PDL 1 works in a
wide range of tumors with a moderate
percentage of responders and good safety
phone profile so it's a good foundation
to build on
and it subtracted now a multitude of
researchers in academia and pharma and
we know we can do better and multiple
preclinical clinical studies are now
identifying ways to do better on really
human creativity has been unleashed and
we're really learning to do better we
need to identify who will respond to PD
one blockade and what are the mechanisms
of failure to respond because it doesn't
work in everyone it works in about 20%
which means it doesn't work in about 80%
so it does it not work because there are
other immuno inhibitors
or failure of immune cells to infiltrate
the tumor or that the tumor doesn't have
enough mutations to generate good Neil
actions also what are the secondary
mechanisms of failure to respond
expression of other amino inhibitory
receptors like 10 3 or loss of MHC
molecules so I think the future of
cancer therapy decisions is first going
to be guided by precision medicine we're
going to sequence tumor genomes and the
sequence of tumor genomes of an
individual patient first they can tell
us those on those populations who could
respond really well to pd-1 therapy
which patients have PD l1 and l2 genomic
amplifications which have defects in DNA
repair and so lots of mutations such as
the MSI colorectal or other MSI tumors
which have viral genomes and have good
origin targets all those patients will
respond well to at PD one therapies in
addition the sequences will identify
which aqua genes are drug targets and
such as for b-raf targeted kinase
inhibitors and it will also identify neo
antigens in the tumor which could be
made into vaccines to stimulate the
immune response
now the pathologists are going to look
at the tumor and come up with a tumor
immunization score they're going to tell
us how much PDL one PDL IPO and other
immune inhibitory molecules are
expressed by the tumor and that'll let
us choose the best immunotherapy and
combine it with the best targeted
therapy or vaccine so I think this is
the future of cancer therapy now these
are the people in my lab move I've done
the work not pictured here the pioneers
in the lab Julia Brown and Quan Chi um
Yong ping Chau and Kathleen Mahoney sign
home you our picture here and
glioblastoma and immune epistle
chemistry studies APOBEC Chaudhary has
studied the interaction of PDL one Sara
climbed glioblastoma model a shabu a
studied Tim three pink ba album Jude
Yaffe Wow
have all helped develop the PD one
pathway and other and you know
inhibitory pathway antibodies Lily Chi
is a great undergraduate who studied
other combination therapies this work
has been a wonderful collaboration from
its earliest days really beginning with
Clive wood and suka hangzhou in the
identification of the PD l1 pd-1
interactions shown the pathway was
inhibitory and identifying the drum
target um it's been a wonderful
collaboration with Arlene sharp
identifying via the knockouts and in
vivo studies the functions of the
pathway um with Rafi Ahmed and John wary
unexhausted t-cell with Vijay Kuchar on
the pin three molecule with Vicky goosey
Otis on the biology from the earliest
days um with kidney cancer with David
McDermott and Michael Atkins ovarian
cancer with Kumaraswamy George koukos
and at the dana-farber Hodgkin's
lymphoma with Margaret ship a tumor
immunotherapy with Glen dronov um tumor
immunotherapy with David Reardon Bach
Wong Kar T so Lane morasco and
mechanisms of immune evasion with Peter
Hanuman um so I think even better days
are before us thanks and I look forward
to your questions
Thank You dr. Freeman for that
informative presentation okay now we
want to get right to your questions and
input so here's a reminder how to let us
know what you have to say questions etc
can be submitted via the Q&A button at
the lower left we will try to get to all
of you but if not we will be sure to
follow up after the broadcast our first
question is dr. Freeman are there any
predictive laboratory buyer biomarkers
of autoimmune adverse effects and high
PD one therapy there are no markers for
death which would indicate development
of autoimmunity in initial clinical
trials patients with autoimmunity such
as multiple sclerosis aren't included in
immunotherapy trials some have been
include now that the drugs are approved
in some tumor types some patients have
been included um there's just a very
limited clinical experience one didn't
get any exacerbation of autoimmunity I
think one did um exacerbations can be
treated with anti-inflammatory agents
like corticosteroids and others it's
really an active area that needs
investigation and safety assessment
question number two - pd-1 inhibitors
impact the propagation potential of
human tumors in xenografts in n OG icid
or n OD es di d studies in height
general immunotherapy depends on a
intact immune system and the human
tumors
when they're puttin the mouse have to be
put in a mouse which has no immune
system so it's very you can't study
immune response in that model but if you
also add human immune cells you can make
some attempts to study the anti-tumor
immune response it's an area of very
activist research where the the leaders
in the field are developing better
models and um and really there's
additional work needed there to make it
better next question for pathologist
should all laboratories use PD one IHC
scanning in cancer specimens is not
financially feasible I don't think the
immunohistochemistry is a big part of
the cost the we need better biomarkers
because the PDL 1 and mu next chemistry
is only suggestive there's been a lot of
press now on the use of the PDL wand
immunohistochemistry in lung cancer in
lung cancer in a trial that was done
where the cutoff was 50% PDL one
expression on tumor pd one antibody had
it a measurable success if the tumors
had 50% more or more expression of PDL
one in contrast as the cutoff was lower
if the tumors only 5% Express PDL won
the clinical trial um wasn't successful
so PDL one expression
um may be used to guide who is most
likely to respond nevertheless there's a
low but real expression or success rate
in tumors that don't express pd-1 it's
an it's an area that again is under
intensive investigation additional
biomarkers are needed like tumor neo
antigen load the extent of cd8
infiltration into the tumor or we need
other additional combinations of
biomarkers which predict treatment
success
next question doctor Freeman is
immunotherapy first middle last or
combinatorial cancer management it
depends on the tumor type um melanoma is
the most responsive cancer type to
immunotherapy and actually PB 1 is
already first-line therapy there um in
other tumor types
um it needs to be tested to see whether
it's a good successful first line
therapy um
chemotherapy can have a high percentage
of response rate but it and it totally
succeeds for some patients but it fails
and the tumor develops and others so we
need basically a trials that compare
immunotherapy to the best successful
standard therapies of chemotherapy or
whatever the best therapy is to compare
and see whether immunotherapy of is
right start with or whether other
therapies of right
dr. Freeman do pd-1 inhibitors em abs
works better by injecting into the solid
tumor as compared to given systemically
no the drug delivery is always within
the drug delivery the drug delivery is
always with an intravenous injection
there have been um I think I don't think
patients like the idea of multiple
needle sticks into a tumor and the the
intravenous infusion um spreads it
throughout the body and can target
metastases at different sites also I
know there's a lot of creativity going
in to the idea of making antibody agents
which only open up and reveal themselves
when they're actually in the tumor
next question
do pd-1 inhibitors impact the
propagation potential of human tumors so
you know we already asked not when I
apologize let's do another question
number six for a patient who is seeking
anti pd-1 immunotherapy which check
which steps should he take what if this
oncologist does not know about
immunotherapy and what should he do I
probably go to one of the more
research-oriented of medical centers of
which there are multiple ones around the
country those have physicians who are
now have some experience with
immunotherapy and managing patients
there's also a very good site called
clinical trials.gov which you can find
on the web if you find that site
basically all the clinical trials in the
United States are listed on that site
and you can search it you can put in um
say you have pancreatic cancer you can
basically put in pancreatic cancer in
the of the website and then you could
put in a different agents you could put
in PV 1 10 3 lagg-3
vaccine and the website will then search
all the ongoing clinical trials and come
back with a list of where the clinical
trials are being conducted and who to
contact to get on that clinical trial so
clinical trials.gov is a wonderful site
on for identifying of no trials which
are investigating your tumor type
thank you so much dr. Freeman I'm sorry
we don't have time for any more
questions we've had great questions
coming in I would like to thank mcduck
Freeman one more time um dr. Madani
final comments breath it's exciting
times you know that I think that the you
know we're we're having success and we
know how to have even greater success
Thank You dr. Freeman we remind everyone
that today's the webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing on our
website through February 2017 we will
let you know when it's been posted and
we hope you pass that information on to
any colleagues who couldn't take part in
today's broadcast that's all for now we
appreciate you joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye